Deborah Burling who's a good friend and
now I count P
Gall as a friend um yesterday I cried
and today watching that I'm just
mad um emotions run
deep um
um let me be clear President Obama and
Mr
Beckle I am a 911 family member and I
will never ever
forget you are
mistake um I want to say
that you know my brother-in-law
Lieutenant Joseph
gon um it was wor his day off from work
he covered for someone
else um the person he covered on that
day has never been the
same he's uh filled with guilt because
my brother-in-law my sister's husband
left a young wife and two
children and so how do you
reconcile him versus me
I also want to say that I want you to
think
about deeply if we were in the city if
if this attack had taken place in the
city of
Mecca and it had been radical
Pentecostals I count myself as Boran
they had been one of
those that strapped a bomb and wiped out
3,000 Muslims radical Muslims or
moderate Muslims it doesn't matter would
they tolerate a Christian or a cultural
center being built there what do you
think the answer would be I can tell you
what it is it's no there is no tolerance
so I ask you for those of us that have
become
complacent you need to when you
can give your support to Pamela Geller
and all she does because I'm going to
tell you something that other lady went
into hiding but they have
mistaken you're very mistaken am is in
New Yorker so is Robert Spencer I'm from
Brooklyn we're not going
anywhere so I would like for you to
please please please give your support
in any way you can to the people on the
front lines doing this we're not doing
this cuz we want the Accolade we're
doing this I'm doing it I'm involved now
in the Grassroots movement because I
have no choice because my sister n years
9 years later can't look at a picture of
her
husband and my nie has no
father and she is filled with a
void you can't ever
understand there is something in that
little that's missing and what's missing
is her father so don't ask anyone don't
ask the 91 family to ever ever ever
forget we will never forget thank
you hi thank you all of you you here I
will tell you something what you don't
know you didn't
hear and you cannot know about
this uh in my wallet I have
a
same stick to the wallet and there was
in a store and I open the wallet to pay
and kashier she was maybe 20 maybe 18
years old she look at this p picture and
she says oh such a handsome man who is
there she said who is his she saw he's
young it's not my husband of
course my husband little growing up
already and I say this is
911 she look at me like I came from Moon
just now she said what
is
911 I said my dear friend did you live
in the United States do you know what
happened
no believe me it this was not once if
she's now 18 I understand for 10 years
ago she was
eight and parents didn't show this to
her didn't explain it's correct it's
supposed to be like this child but now
she doesn't know and a wife of Iman
Daisy what I met her and I told
everything what I think about both of
them and this was in the Queen's college
and a big
meeting uh not for nothing they make a
trip she goes from college to college
and she
explain about these
kids how beautiful how wonderful is
Islam I believe what you
everyone have to take
disc this one what you saw now you have
a children nephew student of course not
children who go to school who graduate
school it's 17 18 years old it's already
grown up enough but in the college show
your student and they can show to rest
one and rest one until people will don't
know everything they will not trust they
you have no idea you cannot imagine I
know all this movie I saw everything day
at night and I didn't see what so many
people jump out from the window I didn't
I see
one another one I saw another one and I
believe and you believe of course but we
don't know everything that happened
September 11 because our dear m Bush
sent all
family of uh Bin Laden by parts from
Washington to small put on the small
plane
to I don't remember name of the city
next to Washington it doesn't matter not
too far little piece by little pie by
little pie and all 140 people left
Washington push help Bush also has a
business with oil even Russian pop also
have a business with over so what you
can say already and I believe what you
will help a lot if you will take this
disc and give your if you don't have a
this age children your nephew your
friends kids your neighbor you found to
home even put in your home this movie
invite your name it's also they also
me we'll see what they didn't see in
newspaper because this newspaper doesn't
show a
lot what can I do we have to remember we
have to stop this mask I told yesterday
and I repeat now even and we have to
put line like a make in Israel
Palestinian make they put people woman a
front of everybody nobody kill woman we
will stay like a life wall next to this
building let them bring this machine and
Builder and everything through us let's
see and I see military guy here I
believe yes
soldiers no milary just
soldiers
believe it what you also all of you our
children you your future you have to
think about your life your future family
your future children and you people who
can be with us behind us tell your
friends take this movie you have a lot
of friends before you go to diso show
them what life have in another side
also it's no joke israelian HS Dr be
same age and you have to remember I
believe went to diso Friday night and
this disco go up I saw this kid when
they will put
church and synagogue and mask in Mecca
this time we will give it to
them what they want but they never do
this they not stupid don't think that
they stupid they are not and this what
they travel around the
world I don't know who will start to
talk about this but it's our money we
pay for
this I wish help to all family but here
and not here and young people you must
to have kids how God give it to you so
many kids you must
have it's
blessing it's really treasure nothing is
treasure beautiful house beautiful car
it's
nothing it's nothing children they have
to laugh at home if Home full of kids
full of
laughing this is the
heavens God bless all of you God bless
our country and I believe what America
you'll be like she like America was
before this what now doing our president
don't make up America
STS put head high in how
he make I don't know how this called he
put down his head the front of
Kingo doesn't look right America
supposed to keep it like that
oh Lord respect America and this Dy with
our help and P can be
producer it's your second
profession yes God all of
you I I don't I don't think we take
questions I
think we done 1: yeah if you want ask
questions come up as as dep party
Le